[Music]
so matt you've you've been health
secretary culture secretary been in
politics for some years now just tell us
what brought you into politics
well i ended up going into politics
because of something that happened
something very personal and i think this
is often the case for people who end up
in the house of commons
um
the
the what happened to me was that i grew
up in a family of uh with a who ran a
small business um you know when you type
the uh your postcode into the internet
and it brings up your address well uh my
stepdad wrote that software my mom ran
the business
and in the early 90s um in that
recession there was a moment when the
business was very small and uh just
starting to grow
and they had had one main client and i
was a teenager
and the client nearly went bust
and bef
before then i was interested in the
technology i was interested in business
but what what what i came to understand
was that
you know how can a whole family's
livelihood and the people who work for
the business all be on the line you know
the house was on the line the business
was on the line unless a check came
through by that
friday
and it was harrowing as a teenager to
watch my parents go through that
and that made me ask the question how
does the whole system work you know not
just this business not just our family
but how does the whole system work and
that led me to
study economics
and i worked in the business then i
worked at the bank of england and then i
was at the bank of england and and i got
a phone call from a guy i'd met at a
party once
um and um he said why don't you come
they're all
they were all the rage back then
and uh he said why don't you come and
work in in politics and his name was
george osborne ah and he dragged me into
conservative politics and um his deal
was he said uh i can teach you politics
if you can teach me economics when he
was shadow chancellor so i don't know
how successful either of us was
but um the uh i then worked for him and
for david cameron in the great mission
to modernize the conservative party make
sure that we were electable again
and then get into government in 2010.
and this session is about your life and
philosophy
when george osborne comes to you and
asks if you want to go into politics i
mean what is your driving philosophy
what is it that you want to go into
politics for if you were to sum up
the the philosophy the guiding
principles the ideas that matt hancock
represents what are they well
there is absolutely no doubt that
the
purpose of going into politics for
almost everybody in parliament and
definitely for me
is because you have the opportunity to
to
make change and to do and to make your
country a better place and that is why
people go in
in my case
i am a liberal conservative right i
believe that everybody has a
contribution to make to society and i
believe that it's society's
role and the government's role to help
people achieve that so whether that's
through education you know my first job
was in uh i was the skills minister uh
in in education all through helping
people make the most of their lives
through growing a business uh or right
across the board
but it's conservative because i
essentially think that you should try to
do this based on tried and tested
methods essentially empirically right
i'm i'm i'm burkian if you like um and i
i i'm pretty skeptical of grand utopias
so i've got you know i and and i've i've
then been able to apply that way of
thinking in in the different areas that
i've
i've served so i'm i'm an unashamed
liberal conservative in fact you know
liberal conservatism is an area of the
political spectrum that is not um
dominated you know dominant at the
moment um and um i think that you know
people need to be out there making the
argument for a society that is um
socially liberal and economically
liberal because that's the best way that
we help people
uh we build prosperity but it's also the
best way that everybody can live their
lives according to how they want to live
their lives that's really interesting
and you're right liberal conservatism
isn't uh isn't worth sort of a lot of
politics is anymore um you know the
conservative party in the last few years
has shifted towards sort of more of a
nationalism is that something you're
uncomfortable with
um it's something that i am uh you know
i i'm happy to be in a coalition with
um but you know i was in a coalition
with the lib dems for five years at one
point i was both vince cable's number
two and ed davies number two so i was
kind of there um
working with the working with the lib
dems uh i'm it's i'm more comfortable
with being in coalition with the rest of
the conservative party but all parties
are
coalitions i think that we need to be
clearer and stronger about making the
case for a for a for an economically and
socially liberal conservatism i think
that is actually what where that's where
you know where
that that is where the country is is
strong frankly where we're
forward-looking and
active about embracing modernity um both
on it you know across the board on
economic grounds and on on social
questions and if you're part of a
coalition and some of the party you know
is clearly going into a direction that
you're not entirely comfortable with how
much do you say that how much when
you're around the cabinet table are you
actually making a case for
policies that aren't being followed well
you know do you say this to boris
johnson well i've just said it to you um
yeah of course i make the um
of course i make that i make that
argument that's kind of what i'm you
know that's that's that's what i do and
so around there are these debates around
the cabinet table there's debates in
parliament all of the time and you know
so
uh this debate
on monday we're having a debate on the
use of
um
of gm crops right highly controversial
and there are people on the right and on
the left who say no no we can't we can't
use this modern technology but i think
we should feed the world and i think
that we should use modern technology
that or other types of
uh technology in in agriculture now i'm
no great agriculture specialist but i
know where i stand on the principles
of
uh both of
gm crops and um
and like this cultured meat you know the
meat that's actually meat that they grow
in a lab a bit like how we grew the
vaccines very very exciting incredible
technologies
and the key point is to embrace these
things because if you want people to be
able to make the most out of their lives
the government the role of the
government is to
help that to happen and not to get in
the way
well when it came to um some of the big
challenges that you've sort of faced
during your time in government i suppose
one of the first was probably brexit
yeah you working with george osborne
came out very much against you were sort
of called part you know project fear
effectively um do you feel that whole
what was your thinking around around
that around that decision and did you
feel the whole campaign didn't quite go
to plan i mean well it didn't go
do you feel like the campaign was
perhaps you know
you just failed to make the case we
weren't what what went wrong yeah
now um gosh uh it feels like a long time
ago now um what i'd say is that um
that campaign did not
uh
didn't have enough emotion in it it
didn't capture people's hearts
um and
um and and that's the primary reason
that it lost and it didn't it didn't
have a sort of self-confidence
um and
you know the um
but more than that i'm a democrat in
that once the decision was made it was
like okay that decision is made let's
get on with it and not everybody felt
like that and obviously there was then a
debate for some time about what to do
about the vote but i was very clear from
the day afterwards that um you've got to
you've got to
this is that we live in a democracy and
that is more important
than the individual decision
you actually ran for the leadership of
the conservative party sort of on that
basis talking about what should happen
to brexit next
but during the process of running for
for the leadership you know you talk
quite specifically about the issue of
proroguing parliament
you know you said and i quote um
to prorogue parliament would be to go
against everything that those men who
waded onto those beaches fought and died
for
i will not have it you also said a
policy on brexit to pro borough
parliament would mean the end of the
conservative party as a serious party of
government
the the fan club there will applaud
everything but um i think a lot of
people at the time were applauding and
sort of thought that was a very
principled stand
what made you change your mind
[Applause]
well i thought and i think a lot of
people think this thought as well and it
is possible to have these two thoughts
at the same time i thought that it was
also important that given that
boris johnson was clearly going to be
the prime minister and became the prime
minister that there were the broad
spectrum of conservative voices in his
cabinet that's what i thought
and he asked me to stay on as health
secretary and so i did and you know so
of course
is that what those men waded onto those
beaches for
but i think for boris johnson to to
become prime minister and you to become
health secretary yeah i've been asked
this lots of times for obvious reasons
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas